Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I liked the sixteen-ness of your Friday video
so much that I'd do a sixteen part video of
my own today.
Part 1: The intro.
Done!
Part 2: Our one week fundraiser for Save the
Children's work with Syrian Refugees has raised
over $15,000, which means $30,000 with matching,
which is a lot of money and makes me feel
better about the world in general and my post-operative
mouth pain in particular, so thank you.
Part 3: Our podcast.
It's going to be called Dear Hank and John,
or as I like to think of it, Dear John and
Hank.
It'll feature us answering questions from
nerdfighters and dispensing second rate advice
and giving you the latest news from AFC Wimbledon
and Mars.
Nerdfighters, if you want to send us a question
or a problem, you can do so.
We're at hankandjohn@gmail.com.
Part 4: In the meanwhile, you can listen to
the Tour Because Awesome Podcast, featuring
Hank and his friends.
Link in the dooblydoo.
Part 5: Hank, last night I had this weird
dream that my friend Hannah Hart was a professional
trapeze artist working with a trapeze collective
called "The flyerz" with a 'z'.
No real story there, I just wanted to share
that image with you.
Part 6: Hank, DFTBA Records has a new CEO
Jo Garrett.
She's great and she's a nerdfighter, and she's
gonna help DFTBA Records get people awesome
stuff in a timely manner.
I'm so bad at counting.
What part are we on?
I don't even know.
Part 5?
I'm gonna say Part ...7.
Rosianna is here!
Hank, we have stolen Rosianna Halse away from
her native land of England and brought her
here to the United States with a fancy visa.
I can't yet reveal to you the full awesomeness
of this, but soon.
Anyway, part 8: Nerdfighteria sponsored AFC
Wimbledon are going to stay in league 2 again
which is great news!
They finished the season in 15th, so they
are still a full-time professional team, and
if you play the next FIFA game, you can still
be AFC Wimbledon and see our shorts in video
game form.
We also have some of these awesome Nerdfighteria
Wimbledon scarfs still available at dftba.com
-- link in the dooblydoo.
Part 9: In case you're wondering why I'm in
front of this white wall, new video background
coming soon.
Part 10: Over at hankgames, I'm currently
taking a moral journey through the video game
"Grand Theft Auto," exploring the question
of whether people truly wield power or the
will to power ultimately wields people.
Also, how do you play this game without running
over people's feet?
Part 11: Bank of Nerdfighteria update.
So Hank, ad revenue from this channel Vlogbrothers
gets split in half between the Foundation
to Decrease Worldsuck, Nerdfighteria's charity,
and a fund that sponsors educational content
online like "Physics Girl" and "The Financial
Diet."
So far, for this year, the Foundation to Decrease
Worldsuck has raised about $40,000, mostly
from people watching ads on Vlogbrothers,
so thank you for ingesting all of that advertising.
But we've also gotten a bunch of money from
"Tab for a Cause," a browser extension that
allows you to make money for charity just
by surfing the web.
Really does work, it was built by Nerdfighters,
there is a link in the dooblydoo.
Part 12: If you are a teacher or a student
who uses CrashCourse in school your life is
about to get better because thanks to Bill
Gates we are building curricular materials
around the videos like lesson plans, and primary
sources, and other stuff that I don't understand
very well because I am not an educator.
But look for that stuff rolling out before
the new school year.
Part 13: The Paper Towns movie.
Hank, the Paper Towns movie comes out in like
56 days in the United States, It comes out
at different times at different places.
Why?
I don't know the movie business is strange,
but I will be travelling around the world
to support the release of the Paper Towns
movie at least going to Brazil and the United
Kingdom, and also probably some other places.
I hope I'll get to meet lots of nerdfighters.
Part 14: July 24th is not just the release
date of Paper Towns; it's also the first day
of VidCon.
Oh that should be a relaxing day.
Anyway VidCon tickets are probably gonna sell
out in the next couple of weeks, so don't
get mad at me for not saying anything about
how they were about to sell out because I
just said something!
Part 15: Oh my god, I can't believe the Paper
Towns movie will come out in least than two
months, tt makes me feel that weird fear/excitement/strangly-throat
thing.
you know that thing?.
I have a complicated relationship with that
feeling, Hank, but all things considered I
would recommend it over mouth pain.
Part 16: The outro.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.